[Musique]
K
dans certaines régions les bateaux sont
un moyen de transport
incontournable d'escale en escale des
féries chargées à bloc font vivre des
villes et des villages isolés et
affronte bien des dangers pour mener
passagers et marchandises à bon
port sur le lac Malaoui au cœur de
l'Afrique l'ilala assure la liaison
entre les villages de pêcheurs depuis
plus d'un
demi-siècle dans le nord du Brésil
l'Amazone star qui relie manao sabéem a
imposé sa silhouette massive sur le
fluve
amazone au fil du temps ces bateaux sont
devenus des figures emblématique dans
ces régions isolées pour les populations
locales il représent de véritables
lignes de
[Musique]
vie
avec ses 7000 km de long l'Amazone est
le plus long fleuve de la
terre sa largeur sa profondeur et la
puissance de ces courants font qu'aucun
pont ni barrage ne le franchit sur des
milliers de
kilomètres ça démesure le rend unique
mythique
depuis toujours en Amazonie le fleuve
relie les
hommes aujourd'hui il reste encore la
meilleure et bien souvent la seule voie
de
communication tous les jours dans le
port de Manaos les féries embarquent des
centaines de passagers et des tonnes de
marchandises les routes déjà peu
nombreuses sont impraticables pendant la
saison des pluies toutes les semaines
l'Amazone star fait le voyage entre les
villes de Manaos et béem distante de
1600 km avec ses 12 m de large et 66 de
long l'Amazon star peut embarquer
jusqu'à 1200 tonnes de marchandises et
750 passagers pour un prix
modique c'est 300 Réal jusqu'à bélm
jusqu'à bélm mais avant d'y arriver il y
a 12 arrêts donc les prix varient de BM
ici c'est moins
cher à bord le receveur est responsable
lu conf les comms de Manaos tous font
confiance au bateau et à son équipage
pour livrer leur
clients ici en Amazonie le fleuve c'est
notre route le bateau c'est notre bus
grâce à lui on envoie le courrier et nos
livraisons on utilise le bateau pour
envoyer les commandes jusqu'à B on
envoie toutes sortes de marchandises
vêtements
nourriture
sac de tout ça dépend une variété de
choses à Man pour le revendre ailleurs
c'est un service important du
bateau c'est le moyen de transport le
plus
rapide sinon c'est 8 à 10 jours par la
route d'ici il faut prendre soit l'avion
soit le
bateau on a des avions il y a des vols
pour bél de vols par jour mais ce
service est moins pratique plus cher et
moins accessible pour la population qui
préfère le bateau on n pas de route
manao est
isolé pour le moment on a réceptionné
108 colis de
marchandis 108 en
tout on ne part jamais avec moins de s
colis c'est toujours
plus c'est
stressant parce que j'ai beaucoup de
choses à noter
j'ai pas le droit à l'erreur si
quelqu'un attend une commande ça doit
arriver à son nom à
destination fais une erreur c'est une
erreur
àar à cause des pluies d'iluvienne en
Amazonie il est risqué de s'aventurer
sur les pistes boueuses qui peuvent
devenir un piège pour les
automobilistesz avance
avance la voie fluviale est la plus sûre
et surtout la plus
rapide mais l'accès Hok ressemble à un
parcours
[Musique]
d'obstacle le commandant vanerlo Lille
lui a
l'habitude va faire embarquer une
voiture c'est tous les jours pareil on
prend des
voitures dans bientôt 20 minutes on doit
appiller pour un magnifique voyage au
command de l'Amazon star depuis plus de
10 ans le commandant n pas surpris de
voir les passagers donner un coup deain
à
l'équipage une situation qui illustre
bien l'esprit d'ENT dans la
régionou volant pour aller tout
droit mon premier voyage en bateau je
vais découvrir cette expérience j'ai un
peu peur mais la route 319 est en
mauvais état il y a de forte pluie ça ne
passe nul
part je suis arrivé à manos en 2013 ça
fait 4 ans que je n'ai pas vu ma
famille si die veut j'y suis dimanche je
voulais la joutique alors j'ai
réser ça vare une sacré
sensation
[Musique]
l'Amazon Star est un de ces navir que
les Brésiliens surnomment les
gaillolasses des
bateaucages car le balancement des
hamacs pendant la traversée rappelle
celui des oiseaux en cage sur leur
[Musique]
perchoir il faudra 4 jours à l'Amazon
star pour atteindre
Manaos peu de passagers s'intéressent
aux manœuvres de départ sur sur le pont
et c'est la C l'équipe nationale de
football qui assure le
[Musique]
spectacle c'est une grande émotion pour
le
Brésil on est c fois
champion c'est dans le sang c'est dans
le S
le foot et le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
carnaval à l'autre bout du monde le lac
Malaoui est le trème plus grand lac
[Musique]
d'Afrique avec ses 580 km de long et 30
à 80 de large ces eau trèspures abritent
une FO aquatique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
exceptionnel plus de 800 espèces de
poissons sont recensé le lac Malaoui
possède la plus grande variété de
poissons au
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monde des villages de pêcheurs ses
graines le long des
rives Monkey Bay la baie des singes est
l'un des principaux ports desservis par
la MSC la Malawi Shipping
Company ici le mercredi est le jour le
plus important de la semaine le jour où
le ferré à
Coste l'ilala est un vieux monsieur qui
sonne le lac depuis plus d'un
demi-siècle avec une capacité de 350
passagers et 630 tonnes de
marchandise le bateau crée un lien
étroit entre les habitants d'une zone
immense ses horaires sont très
fluctuants soumis aux aléas de la météo
nul ne lui tient rigueur de ses
[Musique]
retards à mon k ceux qui sont venus de
loin et qui n'ont pas les moyens de
s'offrir une chambre d'hôtel ont dû
patienter jusqu'à
l'aube j'ai dormi ici cette nuit ça
s'est bien
passé je fais le commerce du
poisson je vais le revendre un peu plus
loin le problème c'est quand il y a du
vent sur le
lac quand il sou
retard
s'accumule j'y suis
habitué mais c retards ça complique les
[Musique]
affaires la majorité des passagers sont
des commerçants des vendeurs de poisson
d'ex agriculteurs et d'anciens pêcheurs
reconvertis dans le
commerce toutes sortes de marchandises
sont chargé à bord de l'ALA matériaux de
construction nourriture bien de
consommation
[Musique]
le flot de passagers toujours lourdement
chargé ne tar pas les ponts et les
coursives du bateau sont rapidement
[Musique]
encombré victime de son succès le vieux
fer a pourtant été jugé tropagé pour
naviguer misise au Reut deux fois il a
été remplacé par des navires plus petits
plus rapides mais aussi plus cher sous
la pression de la population locale
l'ilala a finalement retrouvé sa place
sur le
[Musique]
lac le bateau quitte son port d'attache
pour une nouvelle rotation pendant 5
jours il va déservir une dizaine de
villages du sud au nord avant de revenir
à
Monke je prends ce bateau depuis
longtemps quand je suis né le bateau
était déjà là il est confortable et très
bon
marché je me sens bien
dessus aucun bateau n'est comparable à
lui
aucunal a une excellente
réputation les passagers se sentent en
sécurité à bord et certains
car dispose d'une cuisine pour les CL d'
bar et d'un restaurant réserv à
l'équipage et priè
[Applaudissements]
cl sur le
la est plus important que n'importe quel
autre
bateau tell grand et propose
cl des Bills en classe économique
qui sont les plus abordables sur ce
bateau juste auudessus on a une seconde
classe ensuite on a un pont en première
classe et sur ce pont en première on a
une classe
supérieure là on a des cabines c'est la
classe la plus
chère vous savez ici c'est venteux
presque tout le temps c'est notre défi
numéro
notre second défi c'est gérer nos
clients certains d'entre eux essayent de
frauder c'est pour ça qu'on nous demande
de faire la chasse au tricheurs de les
ramener et les faire
payer chaque semaine quatre capitaines
de la compagnie se relent au commande du
navire Daniel tasao kanguya est l'un
d'entre eux comme ses passagers
il est toujours ravi de retrouver son
bateau vous savez ce qui est drôle quand
je suis là je me sens à la maison tout
comme je me sens au travail tout au même
endroit vous avez votre bureau derrière
le bureau c'est le bar vous descendez un
étage le restaurant vous
attend c'est une vie magnifique c'est
seulement en cas de très mauvais temps
que la vie change un peu mais ça
n'arrive qu'une fois de temps en temps
pas toujours
j'adore être là et la plupart des
passagers adorent l' là c'est un bon
navire pour rencontrer les habitants du
malaou moi aussi je viens d'un village
où l fait un arrêt quand je veux revenir
chez moi j'ai juste à monter à bord pour
rentrer
[Musique]
au Brésil l'Amazon star poursuit sa
route vers
bélê la navigation semble tranquille
mais elle n'est pas sans risque surtout
en
hiver en cette saison avec les fortes
pluies le fleuve charie des branches et
même des tronss d'arbres alors le
commandant est sur le qui vive
[Musique]
ici il faut faire
attention en ce moment il y a énormément
de bout de
bois on doit être
vigilant des fois on les voit au
loin il fautill pas s'en
approcher jeai pas envie d'avoir de la
casse en prenant un TR dans la
coque au ban de
sable on doit faire attention à la
profondeur pour éviter que le bateau ne
s'échou si ça arrive ça sera très
désagréable parce que on va se mettre en
retard il faudra que je demande
l'assistance d'autres bateaux pour
récupérer mes
passagers
vanerlo est à la fois le commandant du
navire et le
pratico c'estàdire celui qui connaî
chaque recoin du fleuve et chaque danger
mieux que
personne c'est sur lui que repose la
sécurité des passagers une lourde
responsabilité dans cette partie du
monde ici on est dans une région
tranquille le plus dangereux c'est entre
et ont été
attaqu il y a des pirates dans ces coins
et on a
peur mais il n'y a pas que les pirates
le FL amazone est dangereux et les
naufrages sont fréquents la peur de
couler dans une zone infestée de Piran h
les
esprits je me souviens d'une histoire
qui s'est passée en
2002 un bateau en bois coulé à pic dans
la baie
Mar un ami à moi commandant de bateau
est passé à ce
momentl quand c'est arrivé il n'a pas pu
faire
demi-tour pour porter assistance à
l'autre bateau parce que le sien était
déjà plein de
passagers et il ne pouvait pas mettre
ses propres passagers en
danger il y a eu entre 16 et 18 victimes
lors de
ce
[Musique]
ça me plaît de voyager de façon
originale comme dans ce
bateau parce que je veux être en hamac
avec 200
personnes person
j'aurais pu prendre l'avion dormir à
l'hôtel mais si j'avais pris l'avion
j'aurais raté
ça gar est un globotteur il s'est lancé
dans une série de long voyage les plus
authenti possi pour lui un périple sur
l'Amazone dans les mêmes conditions que
la population locale est une expérience
incontournable le Brésil est
incroyable parce que les G sont
trèsimbl prend un cliché on m'autorise
d'un
sourire c'est la joie dans tout le pays
je voyage depuis 15 mois et j'ai visité
100 pays dans le monde et j'aimerais les
visiter tous c'est important pour moi de
découvrir le monde avec mes 5
sens avec la vue le toucher l'odorat
l'ou plus que de le voir à la
télé pour moi le monde est
incroyable il n'est pas dangereux comme
certains le pensent piensan que lo
[Musique]
es
est en plein milieu
our de
gens je dois passer
pardessous je sais pas si la nuit sera
bonne
peut être bonne ou pas ça dépend des
gens
autour pas Mo je ronfle
ça dépend personne ne peut
[Musique]
dire je prends toujours le
premierart de 18h à
min à 6h c'est le tour du commandant en
second avec de
marins parce que c'est la partie de nuit
où il faut être doublement
attentif il reste à TR parce que c'est
l'horaire le plus
difficile mais j'aime ça c'est une belle
vie ça fait 13 ans que je navigue sur
l'Amazon
star je suis habitué à voir le soleil se
leverou
coucher
quand j'étais commandant en second je
profitais des lueurs de l'aube au lever
du soleil quand j'étais à la barre
jusqu'à
6h on tombe amoureux de
[Musique]
l'Amazonie à 9000 km de là sur le lac
Malaoui les annonces lentement les
passagers de
[Musique]
l'a à l'aube du deè jour l'ALA
s'approche de la ville de makjila quite
le Mozambique sur la rive orientale du
lac ici pas de por ni de qu ni de ponton
c'est en chaloupe que les passagers
seront amenés à terre les membres de
l'équipageenent pour le
débarquement je n'ai jamais eu de
formation pour devenir
mécanicien j'ai appris sur le tas depuis
que je travaille ici et aujourd'hui j'ai
suffisamment
d'expérience je fais ce travail pour
aider ma
famille parce que je suis l'aîné de 5
enfants a pas de problème sur les
moteurs mais il faut quand même vérifier
que tout
fonctionne les passagers vont bientôt
débarquer et d'autres
embarquer on arrive bientôt à l'étape de
Mila même si les moteurs marchent on les
vérifie avant chaque
arrêt à bord vérifier que le matériel
est en état de marche est une priorité
le vieux bateau n'est jamais à l'abri
d'une
avarie pour son capitaine Daniel
tangya une fierté de ce navire
prestigieux vestige des anciennes
colonies
[Musique]
britanniques ce bateau a été construit
en Écosse à Glasgow en
1949 il a été remorqué du Royaume-Uni au
Malaoui et reconstruit au Malaoui ce qui
a pris environ 5
ans et a commencé à naviguer sur le lac
Malawi en
1955 VI bateau avec de viux instruments
ce qui r très difficile à
Man voici la bar de 1949 elle est
d'origine et elle fonctionne encore a
c'est d'origine c'est notre seule
boussole on la ce on a un sérieux
problème
on a des
télégraphes c'est ce qu'on utilisait
pour communiquer avec la salle des
machines c'est le télégraphe d'origine
du
bateau on le conservesi parce que c'est
bronze et que c'est une pièce qui permet
aux autres de voir comment c'était en
1949 peu comme un musée mais en cas de
problème tu peux remplacer une pièce par
une autre il
repart si le moteur ne marche plus on
retire l'ancien pour en remettre un œuf
et il repart actuellement les moteurs
que nous avons ont été installés en
2014 à chaque panne sérieuse on essaie
toujours de le remettre en
état je suis certain que si on
l'entretient ce bateau peut encore
naviguer 40 ou 50
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans l'ilala a jeté l'encre en face de
mandjila les premiers passagers prennent
place dans les chaloupes qui vont les
conduire jusqu'au
[Musique]
rivage dans le même temps des barques de
pêcheurs chargés d'hommees et de
marchandises se dirige vers le bateau
chassé croisé trépidant et périeux de
départ et
[Musique]
d'arrivée vous ne pouvez pas imaginer
comment ces gens embarque au-delà de la
charge maximum avec plein de sacs des
bagages c'est difficile de contrôler les
gens quand ils voyagent ils oublient la
sécurité ils sont juste pressés
d'embarquer ou
débarquer c'est un travail
épuisant dès qu'on a jeté l'encre on ne
peut pas dormir on doit surveiller on
peut pas se reposer il faut vérifier
l'embarquement gérer les gens qui
s'amassent voir si les chaloupes
ramènent les passagers au rivage sil
faut arrêter la manœuvre à cause du
vent on ne peut pas se permettre de
perdre le bateau ou de perdre nos
passagers on doit être présent chaque
seconde pour veiller au
[Musique]
grain des freurs se glissent parfois
dans les barque des pêcheurs et
profitant de la pagaille se fauile àord
sans payer leur
[Musique]
billets aujourd'hui sur la quinzaine de
villages desservis par le ferry TR
seulement sont équipés d'un
[Musique]
quai
au Brésil il est à peine 6 he quand
l'Amazone
debquerelques passant
de les le pejeuner
loc Meille du
[Musique]
Brésil
il y en a
encore 5 R qui en veut 4 R pour la belle
gosse les vendeurs ingénieux pratiquent
le système D pour vendre leur plat au
plus vite ils suspendent la nourriture
au bout de leur perche et récupère
l'argent dans des culots de bouteill en
[Musique]
plastique regarde
ça 10 R et c'est bon ig che nous tu peux
goûter si tu
[Musique]
veux
à chaque voyage l'Amazon star transporte
près de 2 tonnes de
marchandises les sacs ne sont pas
contrôlés au départ et nul ne sait ce
qu'ils contiennent du moins jusqu'à ce
qu'on arrive à
Obidos c'est à cette escale que la
police fédérale entre en jeu tous les
bateaux y sont systématiquement
[Musique]
inspectés
leur mission trouver des armes et
surtout de la drogue l'Amazonie est une
plaque tournante du trafic de drogue et
le fleuve est la voie royale pour la
transporter les trafiquants tentent de
passer entre les mailles du filet en
disséminant de petites quantités dans
les bagages des passagers qu'il
soudoit il sont responsa de le
drog ils onination le
tra et le passeur la donne à quelqu'un
qu'il ne connaîtra que le jour même et
s'il ne la donne pas il vaut mieux qu'il
disparaisse il y aura des conséquences
c'est soit la prison soit la fuite s'il
perd la drogue il perd la
vie les bateaux sont passés au peigne
fin
déc jusqu'au bagage des
passagers
c'est une route de trafic de Manaos à
béem tout passe par
ici ils vont où il y a beaucoup de
bateaux et là ils essaient de répartir
la drogue
elle est divisée sur différents bateaux
dans des petits
bagages et ensuite des gens prennent le
risque le plus souvent les passeurs sont
des femmes avec leurs enfants
elles profitent de ce type de trafic
elles savent qu'avec des enfants si
elles ont de la drogue elles n'iront pas
en
prison au tribunal ils vont les
[Musique]
libérer quand certains nous vont
embarqués ils abandonnent leur
bagage pour éviter d'être
identifié il les laisse à côté de ceux
d'autes
passagers ce qui empêche de les
identifier parce que la personne dira
que ce n pas
que évidemment la drogue ne lui
appartient
pas et comme à chaque contrôle les
policiers d'Obidos vont finir par faire
mouche 7 kg de cocaïne soigneusement
emballé le passager le plus proche se
défend d'être le propriétaire de la
valise abandonnée près de son
hamac je n'ai rien à voir avec ça
quelqu'un l'a laissé là je ne suis pas
un passeur
personne ne m'a payé c'est quelqu'un
d'autre aucun indice ne permettra au
policiers de retrouver le propriétaire
du
sac finalement le bagage sera saisi mais
personne ne sera interpellé faute de
[Musique]
preuve après ce contrôle l'Amazon star
peut poursuivre sa route le commandant
descendra à la prochaine
escale on arrive au port de
santar on est à 40 minutes du
port ça fait une semaine que je suis
loin de chez
moi être à la maison ça n'a pas de
prix après 60 jours je vais prendre une
pause de 2
semaines c'est ça notre
F jours tous les 60
jours je su
cont tout s'est bien
passé super
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voyage
au Malaoui l'ilala a atteint l'extrême
nord du lac il doit embarquer des
passagers dans la baie
[Musique]
deilumba au moment délicat du
débarquement un incident va irriter
George Balong chef de la sécurité
dépêchez-vous
dépêchez-vous un frudeur a profiter de
cet arrêt pour sauter du navire et
rejoindre le rivage à la
nage j'étais occupé
ici il y en a
un qui est arrivé en courant de ce
côté parceil se cachait par
là-basand ilutais occupé il en a profité
en une seconde pour courir de là-bas et
sauter du
bateau il ne voulait pas
payer du coup j'ai envoyé un bateau pour
le corriger et le faire
payer mais le fuyard a pris de l'avance
sur la chaloupe il a déjà atteint le
rivage sous les acclamations des
villageois c'était très difficile de le
rattraper
on a perdu beaucoup de temps
ici lui il filait la nage pendant que le
bateau revenait pour faire embarquer
d'autres
gens avant de repartir pour le rattraper
du coup on l'a
[Musique]
raté après cet incident
le responsable de la sécurité se montre
intraitable avec les passagers en
[Musique]
infraction rapidement le ton monte avec
un groupe de femmes sill qui lui tient
tête
je leur demande d'aller acheter leur
billets mais elles essayent
d'esquiver du coup je dois les obliger
parce que c'est mon
rôle aller acheter un billet et elles me
répondent qu'elles ne veulent pas se
lever parce qu'il y a trop de
vent mais je leur répète d'y aller et
d'acheter leur
billets
à chaque escale c'est la même chose
l'équipage doit non seulement contrôler
ce qui embarque mais aussi facturer un
supplément pour les marchandises et les
bagages
[Musique]
encombrant dans notre règlement chaque
article est un bagage
facturé mais Audel de 10 articles selon
le type de
bien par exemple ces sacs on les facture
en fonction du volume parce qu'ils
occupent beaucoup d'espace donc on
facture au
volume parfois on s'accroche avec des
gens qui embarquent sans
argent certains qui chargent
ici si je dis qu'ils ne peuvent pas
charger sans payer ils font des
histoires ça prend des proportions pas
possible
si le passager refuse de payer on doit
s'asseoir négocier et trouver une
solution avec
[Musique]
lui chaque passager doit avoir son
billet quand ils essayent de nous
provoquer on use de nos
pouvoirs s'il refus de payer on les
menotte ou bien on les amène
à chaque
rotation fait une courte escale sur les
du Mozambique une pour les comms qui
sont nombreux
àision plus du
bus
entre le plus de marchandis en
particulier des il des articles du
continent sur les pour les revendre
habitué des traversé F Holland vend ses
marchandises sur l'île de
[Musique]
lioma là c'est les légumes et les huiles
de cuisine on a aussi de la vaisselle et
de la
bière avec ça on tient une semaine c'est
pour ça que je fais le voyage chaque
[Musique]
semaine grâce à des amis qui étaient
allés à l'ikoma il y a 10 ans j'ai su
qu'il y avait un business de légumes sur
l'îala pour l'Î de
licoma parce que lioma on ne cultive pas
de légumes le sol est trop
sablonneux et ils font tout venir du
continent depuis des années je voyage
pour mon
travail ça fait 10 ans que je voyage sur
ce
bateau avant je le prenais deux fois par
mois maintenant c'est quatre fois par
mois dans ma vie j'ai dû faire quasiment
500 voyages sur ce bateau je voyage sur
l'ilala parce qu'il est
sûr car il y a d'autres moyens de
transport plus rapide comme les bateau
en bois mais ils ne sont pas
sûr ici les gens avec qui on voyage sont
tous diplômés de l'école de marine sont
il sa comment gérer les vagues sur le
lac si vous faites un tour sur l'AL vous
verrez qu'il y a des gilets de sauvetage
les gilets sont adapt à la capacité du
bateau en cas d'accident il peuvent
distribuer à tout le
monde estti plein sud et poursuit sa
tournée des
[Musique]
villageant dir les îles de l'OMA et
[Applaudissements]
tiizououu
[Musique]
au Brésil après une escale d'une nuit
l'Amazon star s'apprête à quitter la
ville de santarê pour la dernière partie
de son
voyage
ce matin le bateau fait le plein de
nouvelles marchandises et de nouveaux
voyageurs je ne prends que le bateau
c'est le meilleur moyen de transport
parce que c'est le moins dangereux et j
suis habitué 35 he de voyage encore
avant
l'arrivée chacun cherche la place la
plus confortable possible jeaccroche
là met le plus haut pas meure place mais
on est arrivé en retard on ne peut pas
être làun à côté de l'autre on est les
uns sur les
autres moi ça me
plaît j'ai grandi et été élevé sur les
bateaux j'ai beaucoup voyagé j'aiété
commandant mais maintenant je ne suis
que voyageur je connais quelques
personnes sur le bateau et comme j'ai
l'habitude je reconnais les paysages et
les endroits où on passe je le trouve
très bien ce na on voyage dans de bonnes
conditions le port de santarê est avec
celui de béê le plus proche des
États-Unis il accueille des navires
transatlantiques qui depuis le Brésil
exportent du soja vers le monde
entier au fil de l'eau le décor change
les larges rives de l'Amazone se
resserrent en Rio tortueux au méandre de
plus en plus étroit qui se faufile au
cœur de la forêt amazonienne les
Brésiliens
pour qui conna pas la route de B c'est
un véritable
labyrine l'équipage de 24 personnes ve
dans la salle des machines le chef
mécanicien assure la bonne marche du
moteur au même moment juste auudessus de
lui c'est en cuisine que ça s'active
dans des conditions de travail pas
toujours
fac machines sont juste
là sour infernal
c'est l'ENF tout le monde en profite
c'est l'enfer mais le bateau doit
continuer comme ça jusqu'à
B lev à l'aube le chef cuist sactive à s
fourneau et
cerol il sont tr en cuisine pour
préparer les REP des 750 passagers et de
l'équipage je trava de 4h du matin
àh
et je reprends de 15h à
20h pour préparer la cuisine pour que
tout soit
prêt les grillad les plats les fritures
ça fait beaucoup 50 K plus ou
moins c'est pour l'équipage et la
vente c'est long et fatigant mais je
suis habitué très
habituéme ma femme à la maison elle est
habitué j'aime l'Amazone c'est à nous
è regardez autour de vous c'est une
merveille l'Amazone c'est
pourous c'est
TER j'aime tout ce qui vient d'ici ici
on boit du lait
maison beaucoup de gens se plaent de le
vie chez nous non on a tout ici on a
tout
restants bon mais je préfère
voyager regardeer la vue faire des
allersretours c'est ça la
[Musique]
vie aux alentours de la ville de brve
les passagers assistent à un curieux
spectacle les habitants de la forêt ont
pris pour habitude de s'approcher du
bateau avec leur pirogue au mépris du
danger il saccroch au navire en marche
avec des cordes pour éiter
équipage est régulr oigé
[Musique]
d'intervenir le but des piruers vendre
des fruits et légumes de la forêt et des
poissons du
fleuve ils nont rien à faire là les
passager de ce bateau représente une
clientèle pour
nous
en plus iluvent demander
beaucoup ils on déjà demandé jusquà 50
R crevettes il vend de la viande il
prent de la
farine VI a des produit de le
exploitation qu'il y a des mineurs
avec devra avoir que des
adultes
[Musique]
après 4 jours de navigation l'Amazon
star arrive à bélm sa destination
[Musique]
finale
à peine à quai le bateau se vide de ces
passagers de ses
véhicules les retardataires prennent
leur temps avant de rejoindre leur
famille livrer leur marchandis ou
continuer leur
voyage si les passagers ont atteint leur
destination finale le bateau lui n'en a
jamais fini après une nuit de répis
l'Amazon star va reprendre le chemin du
retour au cœur de
[Musique]
l'Amazonie alors que l'Amazon star est
arrivé à destination l'ilala
encore sur le lac
Mali le temps se
[Musique]
GTE Mali petit sur une carte de
l'Afrique mais parfis il peut-être
rude très
dur on a d affronter ce qu'on appelle
les grands
vents
ce sont des vents qui soufflent dans une
direction très
[Musique]
souvent sur le lac Malaoui on a des
vents de nord-est des vents d''est et
des vents du
Sud-Est et parfois c'est dur des fois on
va à certains endroits on descend
l'encre on sort les
chaloupes pour amener les gens à terre
et en
ramener avec ces vents c'est dur de
ramener des gens du rivage avec les
chaloupes mais sur le bateau ça
va quand le vent du sud-est se lève
c'est un des plus
puissants et parfois on ne peut même
plus naviguer sur le
lac parce que ces vents peuvent générer
des vagues de plus de 6
[Musique]
m
et on a des vagues jusqu'au
nord vous n'imaginez pas comme elles
peuvent être
énormes et le bateau fait l'ascenseur
tout le monde a le mal de
mer parfois ça nous prend 10 à 15 he
pour couvrir une distance qu'on fait
habituellement en 6
he ce sont les risques du lac
c'est notre pain
quotidien on fait ça comme n'importe
quel métier mais quand ça nous arrive
dessus on s'écarte pour aller se mettre
à
l'abri il y a beaucoup de gens G on
prend
soin on est responsable de tout le
mondeord
sur les eaux du lac Malaoui ou sur
l'Amazone assurer le transport la
sécurité et le confort des passagers est
au cœur des préoccupations des
compagnies de
fer des régions les plus reculées
d'Afrique aux villes isolé d'Amazonie
l'ilala et l'Amazon star participent
activement au développement économique
d'une zone
immense pour les populations locales
coupé du monde ces fer qui ont imposé
leur silhouette dans dans le paysage
sont devenus indispensables ils
rassemblent les familles apportent leur
lot de marchandise permettent aux hommes
d'échanger de partager et de
vivre ces ferries sont leur ligne de
[Musique]
vie